it's a complexity thing doing
interactive proofs essentially the proof
of IP equals P space in the morning
following by followed by P CPS in the
afternoon it's very heavy so let's to
make it as interactive as possible ask
me as many questions as possible so that
I don't cheat and throw things under the
rug so it goes on so the plan for this
one is going to occur sort of give an
outline of what proofs are verification
see make a gradual introduction and
define what PCP is piece of piece sort
of proofs that allow for su super fast
verification we will then see the
statement of the PCP theorem discuss
sort of implications of it what it means
in our context of fast verification and
then having spent about 30-40 minutes on
this the remaining sort of six amount of
time I'll try to give a bird's-eye
overview of the PCP construction how
does one construct such proofs that are
extremely fast verifiable and extremely
efficiently and depending on how much
time I have later on towards the end we
will talk about even making the
verification we even sub linear time not
just okay that's good started so what
did we see in the morning we saw the
morning of this sort of thing in which
there is a sort of a week or a
computational model which
just wants to perform some task D Orsay
it wants to under find out of some
statement which I will call a theorem T
is true or false
it's takes the help of a very powerful
computationally powerful which
completions the task or proof or says
whether a ste or say proves the team
says as a true or false for the theorem
statement and with the weak model does
not trust the server so we then had they
then had a conversation back and forth
was a form of question challenges and
responses
at the end of which the client sort of
either accepts or rejects and the
important point over here is we allowed
sort of interaction and we allow the
client to toss random coins to make the
check that was important the fact that
the verify what was called verify this
was called verifier in the morning and
allowed two from our usual notion of
verification we had two extra features
one is the feature of interaction that
is you're allowed to ask questions back
and forth with the prover and second
thing is these questions are sort of
randomly generated and it was important
to have this randomness we saw then some
most cases randomness really gave you
the extra power we not always do we have
the pleasure of having to be able to ask
this extra approval these challenges in
response for example you get to know
that you prove it tells you the answer
and then you want to check off somehow
check it later on if this answer is this
the task is actually been accomplished
or true or false so you don't pay
necessarily or you're not interaction is
not always a feasible not always
feasible this could also be just because
it's not one single so the entity that's
computing the competition does is it's a
distributed entity and it's hard to it's
the interaction is an expense of this
one so and what expect in such cases is
actually to prove the the prover not
just instead of interacting with you
sort of public gives you out something
it publishes a proof which you could
sort of the check to see little instead
of interaction the prudence of pruer
provides proof that allows the verifier
to do whatever over here
to check if task was performed
successfully a theorem was
but once we come to this model we are
going to the classical model of NP in
which there is some statement that the
verifier wants to check exist the prover
the all-powerful prove it is trying to
perform this task and then at the end of
it not just perform the task it gives
out a proof stating with the task has
been performed as we are going into the
classical definition of m NP of course
you could because we're also allowing
randomness this could also be what is
also called Merlin author pro system but
let's ignore that this is this we are
going into the sort of the encryption so
let's just look at a few examples what
we want to know check in all of these
cases our main goal is sort of to make
the goal and all of these is to make the
task of the verifier as efficient or
simple as possible and we will define
these notions as we go
what could be some examples on some such
tasks well no I'm just going to recall
some classical and P problems and says
examples of theorem proofs the way I am
going to you be using the word theorem
and task sort of equivalent Li task is
something to be accomplished you have
some particular task and also theorem is
going to use these sort of this one and
and I don't what the proof of this one
for example I could ask this I give you
two numbers three numbers ABC three
integers ABC or the two integers lengths
and asked he has a device so let's
assume B is less than equal to C he has
a divisor in between B and C one such
this one does this one this is a hard
computational task it's hard for the any
weak computational model to sort of do
this sort of model but of course the
clear answer is a proof for this is
actually a provide a divisor D that's
one proof a with the class could say yes
or no and then could provide divisor D
ask if you have you're asking you want
to solve a linear programming problem we
want to say maximize
a transpose X subject to some
constraints and this is an expensive
Swan one set of proof
there are several proofs here one is
this is it says problem soluble and Peep
you know interior point method sort of
solved this and the brewery an expense
approver could solve it send it across
and give the entire computation history
of the computation tab lower this one of
the solution as proof see if it could
give you the solution and also the hold
his computational history so you to
check that this is a valid proof and
then of course there the classical
np-complete problems disease you are
you're given see say some 3sat instance
say of the form X 1 or X 5 X 8 X 9
you're asking is this satisfiable and
the proof here is a satisfying
assignment all familiar with this I'd
put in one more thing then there's a
classical case of three coloring you're
given a graph G you won't ask is it 3
colorable the proof here will be some
coloring of the vertices so this was you
will have to go to talk about so the in
all of these cases in the Esk we're
talking about sort of theorem we what we
want you're asking is what's the
completeness and soundness of we are
talking of a blue underlying proof
system so you want to say if the answer
is yes there must be a proof that
convinces you this one if he is the
answer is no no matter what proof you
give you should never be able to be
convinced that the answer is this one so
it's all it all of these has this
one-sided feature they might be problems
which have both proof of membership as
well as proof of non-membership both in
the SN no keys which we'll be talking
about processing somewhere right is
right right just write that down so so
what is what is it in all of these we
have there's an underlying proof system
going on here so there's this theorem X
or theorem T that I want to check
whether it's true or false as this task
has been accomplished so this verifier
so what the proof truer is publishing as
is publishing a proof pie and the prover
is theorem verify reads the theorem and
the proof pie at the end of it says
accept or reject this the classical
notion of sort of we have a
deterministic very fair and what do we
want of this we want the following two
features was what I'm going to call
completeness is if theorem is true
then they must exist a pipe such that
the verifier verifier of peopie accepts
and soundness is false no matter which
proof you give me the verifier should
always reject the sort of it should and
because we want to maintain polynomial
ax t want to maintain verify the proof
should not be any longer than Paul
if the verifier has to be efficient the
proof the proof that is being sent back
to the refer should be just polynomially
long it can't be longer than that
because otherwise the very fat doesn't
even have time to read the entire so
this is what weight class familiar with
what we want to ask is all that the
verifier wants to know is the theorem
true or false it doesn't need to look at
the entire proof to check the veracity
of the theorem it it just did this one
bit of information has the task been
accomplished correctly or not is the
theorem true or false it's it doesn't
trust the proof person who's providing
the proof but it wants to do this stuff
it doesn't need to read the proof in its
entirety to check whether the proof so
once a question you're going to ask is
is there a much more more efficient way
of checking this proof so what we will
do is we are not going to strengthen the
power of the verifier we are going to
make it a little randomized so far it's
not been tossing random coins I'm going
to ask can I give a slightly different
proof that's being prude can I give a
different proof which we have a very
fair at this time it's a randomized very
fair
for instance the reason I would like to
ask us in some of these cases for
example in the in this case of the this
problem if the verify if in the case of
the LP problem if you're going to give
the proof is going to be the entire
computation table there is no point in
actually delegating the task to the
brewer because essentially the only way
the verifier is sort of checking it's
running through the whole algorithm in
its entirety to check if the algorithm
is run correctly you want to somehow
make the task of the verifier more
efficient than actually doing running
the entire task so we can ask us with
we're gonna can have a randomized verify
we're going to ask if such a verifier as
possible which is going to potentially
toss random coins you random coins of
course it's going to read the theorem as
before and I mean this it's going to
read the theorem but then based on the
theorems and the random points it
doesn't read the proof in its entirety
but decides to probe the proof I'd say a
few locations say some 10 locations and
then based on these locations decides to
accept whether the proof is correct or
not it would be great if we had such a
proven and this is what I'm going to
call this so this is what I'm going to
call and furthermore now given that it's
randomized I never need to check what
the completeness and soundness of of
this system is what do I mean by the
same thing out here if if the theorem is
true then what we want is they want
there exists a pipe such that the
verifier
is this visible or should I lighting
port that's true thanks that's true you
want one such proof which the prover can
provide says that the verifier when it
probes this proof accepts with high
probability for now less as Justin had
done in this case let's say it accepts
all with probability 1 and they in the
completeness case but in the soundness
case what we would want us if the
theorem is false then just like out here
you can't give me any proof that is
going to convince me convinced to verify
that the one but you can't expect it to
probability of Z acceptance to be 0 over
here because you're only looking at the
proof at a very few location so what you
can ask is the following sort of only
one for all pipe this one the
probability that the verifier
except say it's less than 1/10 this is
this 1/10 is an arbitrary number we
could just drive it down as small as
possible by repeating the process
several times over the zero process and
question is what we would like to know
is it would be amazing if every such
Brewer every such proof can be written
can be rewritten in this form that
allows for such an efficient
verification
this would allow so in other words in
order to test this whole thing all that
the verified needs to read is just these
few locations and make some predicates
on it and then I could accept or reject
based on it it sort of it's it's
guaranteed or the veracity of the proof
without looking at the whole proof and
it it's sort of as long as you're
willing to allow for the small amount of
error so by strengthening the verifier
from going from a deterministic purifier
to a randomized verifier we have made
the task of the verifier even more
simpler than ever before so it was
previously it had to read the proof in
its entirety to check if the proof is
valid or not and here you want to do
this so this is a sort of useful task to
such a thing where true sort of useful
to have because whenever you have a very
powerful server is sort of computing
performing a very intensive task it can
along with it provide a proof that
actually the task has been accomplished
in this format so this is not the
standard proof and you will need to read
the proof only at a few locations to be
guaranteed that actually the task has
been performed correctly or not so what
we'd like to know is do can proof be
written this way and in fact what the
celebrated PCP theorem from the early
90s sort of says is this is in fact true
and I will say in what setting of
parameters how many queries how many
randomness that is every proof can be
rewritten in a format such that it can
be checked super efficiently in fact the
number of queries is as long so this
[Music]
yes every problem in NP
there exists randomized verifier be
that arses at most
order login random coins so the number
of coins made by this verifier is
extremely small it's just log n n this n
will always be the length of the input
for me log in random points and just
constant number of queries so it says
that any such thing has allows for such
a super-efficient verification in which
you don't need to go and read the proof
in its entirety you can read the proof
at very few locations and still be
guaranteed of the veracity of this one
and this whole thing is in short
succinct written in the following
fashion NP is contained in PCP 1 1/10
we do have that every proof can be
rewritten in a format that allows for
super efficient verification this is
statement sort of claim ya know we would
say that most of the tech so what will
happen so so if this were a 3sat
instance or a 3 colorable instance in
the S case we will give some things as
that it's always going to pass the test
in the no case you're going to say most
of the time nine-tenths of the time you
will be no matter what proof you give me
however the prover tries to cheat me
whichever prefigured 9/10 of the time
you'll find a local inconsistency in the
proof notice that for 3sat for a 3sat
instance to be false
it could be false in just so a natural
local test should be could just be give
me the satisfying assignment pick a
random clause and go and probe the three
variables that participate in the clause
and check if that clause has been
satisfied or not but 3sat could be false
just because every assignment while it's
only one clause not a constant fraction
of clauses every assignment possible so
if you are allowing this to be like one
if you allow this to be like one minus
one over n then this is almost trivially
follows from the statement of from NP
completeness this one what I'm claiming
is not 1 by n 9/10 it is actually going
to 9/10 of these local views are all
going to reject so we knew that there
was one rejecting view if the fact that
is false means that every proof has at
least one place where the proof is
fallacious and now I'm claiming that
it's not just one place this sort of
error is sort of smeared across no
matter what you do the error is sort of
smeared all over the proof 9/10 of them
is going to Q are going to catch their
answers
and okay so what are some features of
this one so let's actually just remark a
few things on
a few things that would be important for
us is yeah this is great that you can
every such proof if we prove that was
written in the classical NP way has now
another proof now which allows for the
super efficient verification what we
could ask is this certainly now question
is how easy is it to do this
transformation the proved true or who
managed to do this computation god this
proof can you find this rewritten proof
so we would be interested in the
following features that is the prover
overhead now even before that what I
want to ask is you want to say that the
new proof is not too long compared to
the old proof
well no Mian or even or normally long or
even almost linear
that's one thing which we want other
thing we want is the prover overhead
income in rewriting proof is the
verifier running time very fair said
it's super efficient in the terms of the
number of locations it's going to probe
in the proof but you can also ask how
much running time it's going to take to
then first decide to accept or reject so
we could ask all of these if all of
these are in a favor then this forms an
excellent way of rewriting every proof
that is you have a huge task you give a
proof of the tasks being accomplished
and you can sort of allow for extremely
efficient verification to find the
subproblems with these two things out
here one is whether the amount of time
for the prover to solve the original
task so let's assume they were joking
that 3sat itself are you asking the
reduction to 3sat something both parties
verifier and this one we assume can do
it
of their own between act in some of the
applications later on which I will see
we will actually do it problem specific
we will not do the reduction to 3sat we
will take the particular problem and
actually construct the PCP for the
specific problem in hand but what I'm
not counting is how much time the prover
actually got to get the original proof
the original proof is just there I'm
only asking how much time it's going to
take to rewrite the original proof given
the proof so there this possibly it has
to do an exponential search to search
for this
or if it's if this was not a such an
expensive task it was it was a
polynomial task then it manages to get
this and then you are asking about the
overhead time so this one is not talking
about amount of time in computing the
proof but only the further overhead
given the old proof how much extra time
does it take to convert it into this new
proof why is such a statement
interesting first is of course it's
mathematically extremely interesting it
says you any paper of us can be
rewritten in such a way such that the
reviewers job becomes trivial they just
need to look at n the locations or
hundred locations in the proof and
they'll be guaranteed of this one so all
papers can be read rewritten in this
format in this way so that it can mix
the task of so it sort of says is the
hard part of a coming of Peru Vista
coming over the proven the verification
is super easy it's the desert you always
thought the ravine process is easier the
critic proc and this says it's not just
easy it's super easy you can make the
number of probes into the proof as small
as you want in fact what we know today
is this if you're looking at the bits if
this is going to be over bits and if you
want this number to be half this number
can be made as small as three you can
just be get look at the proof of three
bits of this look at three bits and be
convinced of the veracity of the proof
so I haven't so I haven't said what is
the running time of the very first
verify it makes three probes but I need
to compare it with how much we will come
to this this is something I will spend a
fair amount to the end of my talk ask
how much time does the verifier tickets
so the verifier we want it to be
efficient we certainly want it to be
more efficient than the deterministic
verifier and we will relate it to it how
much time so certainly it has to read
the theorem so at least it has been
linear in n but then we last what's the
amount of extra amount of time here it
not only had to lead the theorem it also
had to read the proof and so sort of if
the proof was of length L the old thing
was at least linear in N and L we would
expect this to be linear in n but how
better dependence on hell for instance
we will later show that you can actually
get the dependence on L to be poly log n
so it's going to be significantly better
than this verify this verify ranan mean
poly time and L to verify this proof
this one is going to run only in poly
log L so in that sense it's a very fair
it's not it's not going to be constant
because of the query complexity it needs
to do some task to figure out which are
the ten queries or hundred queries it's
going to make in today yeah so this will
the task we will come to when we will
see I will outline some constructions of
PCPs and then we see that we will see
where where the verifier running time is
going to arise so what are the
implications of this it's
one of course it's extremely it says
that every proof there is a new way of
rewriting every proofs statement - of
course what we've seen it allows for
efficient verification which is the
interesting to us another application
which we will not go into is this is
intimately related to hardness of
approximation algorithms
just one or two sentences just like the
theory of np-completeness talked about
showed this whole bunch of combinatorial
problems are all equally harder this one
what this fact this one states the very
fact that such a proof exists that a
proof can be read it in this way Willie
may have immediate implications to show
that several of these combinatorial
optimization problems are even hard to
approximate in the worst case this but
this is not a topic of require only this
is not something we will go into this is
our most the fact that these rewriting
of proofs are law for such efficient
verification is what is our most
interesting aspect for us this one so
we'll see what we'll see is what
actually goes into this rewriting of a
proof how do we take such a proof and
massage it to write a rewriter into such
a proof which can be super efficiently
this what I will do is out of the
remaining 90 minutes or so is that a
point or at least 60 minutes of the 90
minutes go into a bird's eye overview of
the proof of this PCP theorem what goes
into how do we take any proof and
transform it into a fashion such that
you can check it super efficiently in
this fashion by looking at the new proof
at just a few locations the statement of
what is the PCP theorem and what is it
clear any questions
we're going to show how anything that
has a usual classical proof in the NP
sense or any proof that is yoga you're
running you have a particular task to be
accomplished somebody performs the task
and gives you a proof that the task has
been accomplished and now I want to
check all I need to check is this task
has been accomplished I need to read the
task but I don't care about what is
actually written in this so is there a
way of rewriting it such that I can be
convinced that this proof is a valid
proof for the theorem over there without
reading all of the proof and it says
that any such proof can be rewritten in
such a way as long as we allow the
verify a few extra random points that is
log in random points and you you
strengthen the verify this way and make
the verifier allow the verified only to
read at a few locations in 100 locations
into the proof how can such a thing be
done so they actually do you notice
there are three nice question such a
transformation requires two things
one is
locality of error every false proof must
be false
you must be so no matter what I'm
climbing over here is no matter what
proof you give me there must be some at
least nine tenth of the location should
locate the should find a proof that
means every false proof every fallacious
proof should have someplace should have
very local errors they should be hundred
places if you look at that hundred just
looking at one hundred places you should
be able to detect this proof is false of
course where the 100 places are could be
hard but you must have this locality of
ever every false proof must have some
local error
does it the PCP clear mistake making
about like computational cost of
checking like it might be here on
nefarious but it might take a very long
time so this is what I've meant by the
verifier running time this question the
question is we will ask we we would for
us the applications at least for where
if this one we would want the very
verifies running time also to be City
the way I have stated the PCP theorem I
only said the number of queries what we
would see later on is the verifies
running time will be significantly
smaller than the running time of this
verify this verifier takes time at least
linear in L the length of this proof
this verifier will sort of we will
eventually see they can construct
verifiers in which the verifier runs in
time only poly log l so it may it might
make hundred queries but it runs it and
we need some amount of time it will be
poly log n and we'll see this later on
are you locality o locality is just them
so for example if they're you given a
3sat instance the fact that it is
unsatisfiable means that there is some
three variables and a particular
particular clause that has been violated
no matter which assignment you give me
there will be some clause of size three
within which look at so there is
locality and just talking about here if
the query complex is 100 there must be
some hundred locations in the proof
which if you look at that hundred
locations you already know for every
proof there must be at least 100
locations then if you just look at that
hundred locations you are able to detect
that the proof is fallacious this is not
a very surprising thing the fact that
3sat is np-complete already tells you
that 3sat is np-complete our graph
coloring is np-complete tells you that
every false proof will have some very
local errors that is track that graph
coloring is NP bleep you the fact you
can transform every statement into graph
coloring and give a proof of the
coloring statement give me a three
coloring of it so if it's not a valid
three coloring there exists a particular
edge that is not satisfied so there's a
locality of two over there so this is
not the very surprising fact its fact
that there's an abundance of local
errors
this is the most surprising aspect of it
that is all that we were able to
guarantee previously that there was just
one local error and now you're going to
say that it's not one local error this
log error over here in the original
three this proof could have been just
Falls because of some three locations
not satisfying a property when you
rewrite it this way stating that you
sort of smearing this error all over the
place so we want this proof writing to
have this extra feature it bus to the
collegia Ferrer this is something which
we know how to do just NP completeness
of 3sat and graph coloring will give you
this but furthermore we want to do this
in such that the errors are smeared
across all that is you can never have
one error in it if of proof is false it
should have abundant errors all over the
place didn't have the locality property
so yeah so that was just going to come
to the thing is morning we saw if you
had two polynomials if we saw that if
they disagree with each other if they
agree with each other they agree
everywhere but if they disagree with
each other then they disagree almost
everywhere it is sort of and if you
could somehow put this disagreement into
this errors into these sort of
disagreements we would be able to
capture them so morning sort of says we
can use polynomials but the question is
do they are they please things also
locally testable we've come to this
extra feature so we will be using what
we what justin built in the morning that
is usually in particular we'll be using
the schwartz appalamma
over and over again stating that if two
polynomials are distinct for if two low
degree polynomials are distinct then
actually they will disagree almost
everywhere this one and we'll use that
feature to actually take the errors and
sort of say if there's a false proof
fact it's false must how the fit must be
the fact that it is false they are over
there all over the place it's not just
at one location
you're going to use this but we need an
extra feature about by the way what I
shouldn't matter mark something about
what Justin said morning so talked about
polynomials having this property it's
not just polynomials that have this
property
aimée error correcting code has this
property you take a code you take any
object in you encode it once you encode
it to messages if they are distinct the
corresponding encoded messages are going
to be distinct almost everywhere that's
the property of error correcting codes
and in fact some of the proofs in the
statement is some of it but it's not
true
some of the things which we did in the
morning could be for example the
Equality protocol we could replace it by
just not just with take the reed-solomon
code word but with any code word room
you could have redone the proof but both
the IP equals P space and this it needs
a little more properties of polynomials
than just the fact it's a code and we
will see some more proper wheel I
mentioned in detail some properties of
polynomials that we will need to
actually get these two features
so what I will try to do in this one is
we're going to try to sort of give a
sketch of this proof but we will do it
in two parts firstly I will sort of
sketch a proof in which even this should
be separating I say that any proof you
can rewrite it an exponentially long
fashion so that it is now testable with
say looking at it at 15 queries even
this fact that you can check a proof
here this the PCP theorem says that this
rewriting can be done with just a
polynomial overhead and say let's let's
weaken on this one I will rewrite this
proof exponentially longer but say that
in spite of it this verifier is allowed
to read this proof only at a constant
number of locations feel sort of as this
will show a baby kiss problem will show
that you can get this sort of a PCP
theorem in which the proof length blows
up exponentially but yet the way
checking becomes constant you don't have
to read the entire proof you can read
the proof only at say ten locations and
be convinced of the veracity of the
proof and then later on we will see how
to will see that some of ideas can be
here further pushed to actually get
polynomial sized proofs in which the
number of queries is not smaller
by the way I should have mention two
things so currently for the proof of the
PCP theorem the fools of PCP theorem we
know two types of proofs one is the
algebraic proof which is the one I will
be following outlining in this one this
is the original work of s LMSs along the
lines of what justin had talked about it
is a proof which uses polynomials as
well actually the proof I will be giving
us actually not the original proof but
with several subsequent improvements
that happened the decades thereafter
today we actually know another proof of
the PCP theorem which is a combinatorial
proof which other combinatorial proof do
to read the notes from 2006 this is not
a proof which I become because the
algebraic proof of
and warm up in sort of
the combinatorial proof has a slight
disadvantage to it the algebraic proof
sort of scale up so they also there's a
way in which it can be done there so
it's a question of the verifier running
time it runs in log L so the way so the
question is how what's the verifier
running time in terms of the original
proof length the original proof length
is L the algebraic proofs can have can
be written in such a way that the
verifier is runs in time just poly log n
and this is useful when you want to sort
of scale this up to mi p equals next per
any such thing the combinatorial proof
does not have this flavor it runs in
poly so there is yeah so it is
conceivable that that can so the way we
know how to make it is use some extra LG
brick constructions into it to make it
this one is we don't have a fully
combinatorial which that has this which
is a useful for the verification
purposes
the general nper this comminuted dinos
proof has this problem that it doesn't
scale for example it will not give a
proof but I don't think anybody has
looked at it from that input length you
want the verifier to be efficient you
verifier is going to run at least has to
read the input once so it's going to be
bit least linear and n the question is
what its dependence on illness and the
combinatorial pulls all have the flavor
that they are pauline l there is in
order to do the scaling up you want them
to be poly in logger than the log of L n
is the length of the L is the length of
the proof the witness to it so all I can
say is this one uses polynomials this
does not use polynomials with notion of
what is algebraic combinatorial is also
going to use the cat it's a guy sort of
a gadget so they use an expander so it's
sort of going to so the combinatorial
proof has this flavor that it's actually
it's not one single reduction there's a
reduction reduction is used based on an
expander graph and there are log in such
but it's a it's a each one you need to
start with some finite the proof when
you say okay use I you know LMS is or a
computer circuit because it's finite
they my question is whether there is an
explicit basis for this she'll have to
start off with an expander on a constant
size thing which has property so you
just do a brute force search or you pick
up one of these
the existence of such a little bit
either booth force or super of the
probabilistic method yeah you pull out
one such thing from there it's no in
that sense there is no algebraic flavor
to them they have expander grass going
on all over them
but they don't have a legit flavor there
is a search for an expander that happens
a constant size expander which one day
there does by brute force or resorts to
the expander grafts coming out of planes
and pollen lines which are algebric
paste expanders exponential size so this
is not what we wanted to do but yet
constant query
I sort of prove this
actually even take the class the problem
which I will work with it could work
with the work is you're given a system
of quadratic equations
question we're going to ask us given a
system of quadratic equations basically
I'm looking at system equations of the
form AI J XJ given several such
equations want to ask yes is there a
boolean setting for the variables X I
that simultaneously satisfies it are
they simultaneously satisfied
this is an np-complete problem that is
you have so I'm going to give a bunch of
quadratic equations something of the
form say X 1 X 2 plus X 3 X 4 6 equals 8
several of such equations say M such
equations and we'll ask is there a bully
and let's assume all family trees I'm
assuming or everything is happening over
0 1 all the constants are from 0 1 and
I'm asking is there a common setting is
there a setting to the variables X so
that that satisfies them completely
simultaneously this is an np-complete
problem so of course a proof for this
the classical NP proof of this will be
their assignment to X itself you give me
X and then the verified just plugs in
those of X variables into each of the
quadratic equations and checks if those
equations are satisfied this will be the
classical deterministic very fair what I
want to write this now is instead of
giving this X as proof we'll give a
different proof such that this proof can
be checked by the verify so
significantly by looking at the proof at
very few locations say just 10 locations
or 12 locations of the proof caveat will
be this proof will be much longer it
will be exponentially long but even then
it's quite a surprising fact that you
can be convinced that the set of
quadratic equations are preferable by
looking at a proof even though
exponentially long but only a constant
number of locations
and actually will make a problem life a
little more easier will actually
this is an easy problem it's just a
solving a linear system and we can solve
this easily just solving there's a
linear system of equations and of course
we know how to solve this this one what
I'll show firstly will give a proof or
this will give an exponential proof but
you know there actually it will be
non-trivial in fact the usual any proof
that we know how to solve this request
am at least n square I can't think of
anything at least time MN it has to look
at the whole input what we will give us
will give a proof which just requires in
which the very verifier runs only in
time linear in n not sort of MN though
it looks at an exponentially small so
even in this case actually we will be
doing something non-trivial this is um
this is a simple case for which the
verify doesn't need the help of a prover
to do this task it's a fairly simple
task solving a system of linear
equations we will show how to give an
exponentially long proof one proof for
this is just give me all the X's and
then you can check that this equation
the satisfied we'll instead instead of
giving this will give the XS in a
different fashion right the X proof in a
different fashion that will convince me
that they are simultaneously satisfiable
and then we will extend it with time
permitting I will show how to extend
this the quadratic equations setting
clear going to do so we have this is the
input we are given to us we're given a
bunch of linear equations and we aren't
to ask is it simultaneously satisfiable
so the classical
NP witness for this you don't need NP
and all for this is just the X that
satisfies it
now instead of egg we are going to give
some so the new PCP roof there will be
some encoding of X
but allows efficiently
introduce what is this encoding and then
we'll go into the trying to prove what
it is in the next half of them
so we'll be using this fact which Justin
had mentioned in the morning dated me
over what's called the Schwartz up and
lemma let P and Q be two polynomials
this one and if P not equal to Q if they
are not identical polynomials then we
are in fact
equal at very few locations in fact at
most locations they are going to be
think we're going to be using this over
and over again in fact we will be using
the multivariate version of this alpha
this was not something with Justin he
mentioned this in passing that is even
the multivariate version of this word
theorem this is what's called the
morning proof of the sum check protocol
we used only the univariate version of
it which is fairly easy to see the
multivariate version requests and it's
easy but it requires it's a non trivial
proof and this is what we'll be using in
fact we will be using it for this case
just for the case D equals 1 we'll just
set the encoding you're going to give is
what is called the Audemars encoding
we're going to encode X an n-bit string
to the N bit string you're going to map
X
it's inner product with every possible
why every possible other will use this
encoding so instead of providing X we
are going to give us proof they this
encoding which is a 2 to the N long
string and show that this string is
going to enable us to do this checking
extremely efficiently so the PCP proof
will in fact be the Hazama the encoding
of X this is what the honest prove will
give you the dishonest prover could give
you something anything something else
and will sit in no matter what he does
the verifier will be robust so that if
there is no X that satisfies it he will
catch it in a constant by looking at the
proof earlier constant number of
locations and most of the time if you're
going to give this function f they
review this review this whole thing as
this function L of X which maps n bit
strings to 0 1 this is in just its
mapping of why
and show after the breakers this proof
though exponentially long it's blows up
the original proof of length Ian into an
exponentially long this one it is
actually extremely efficiently checkup
and all will use is the Schwartz Apple
lemma for D equals one to prove this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]